your skin you're I'm scary double this
one I'm scary I can tell those are eyes
okay
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by Kristen
Stewart she's an actress and director
with more than 20 years in the movie
business which includes a trophy case
full of awards to show for it and some
of the highest-grossing films of all
time you can catch her in Charlie's
Angels her latest film which is set to
open nationwide on November 15th Kristen
Stewart welcome to the show thank you
are you feeling confident closing out
your media day here at the hot ones
table no no simply not I feel like I'm
in line for a roller coaster that like I
want to go on but that I like I think
all at the end I'll be like that was
really fun but right now I'm like why am
I doing this we're on two clients
[Music]
I'm gonna use these guys cuz I touch my
face a lot and I'm scared veteran move
it's like you've done this before or
something I think my hands are shaking a
little bit I should just like chill out
a little bit here yeah hmm cool sweet it
was fine so I want to start with a
compliment from your director Elizabeth
Banks who described you as a legit
action heroine who did many of her own
stunts another a number of high speed
chases and the driving training did you
learn anything that you can take back
with you to Los Angeles you have such a
particular cadence to your voice and
I've seen a few of us know and it's
trippy like this is what you sound like
like I'm like oh you know what I box now
which I'm really into kickboxing I love
anything like overtly physical sometimes
you think speed is the way to go because
you just want you know you want to get
through it quickly to show people that
you're really good at it but actually if
you just move a little bit slower you
walk you see the impact transpire and
oftentimes it'll be like okay we're
gonna go 50% speed and then by the time
you call action actors who are like over
gung-ho or like 150% comes out and
you're like well thank God we told it
all when they go halfway because she
probably would have hurt herself very
badly if we hadn't
[Music]
that's cool I like that so you grew up
in the San Fernando Valley it's a place
in Los Angeles that's maybe unfairly
stereotyped is the epicenter for the
porn industry and the strip malls fun is
it at all a misunderstood place like do
you think people from the San Fernando
Valley or maybe like they have a chip on
their shoulder for the rest of Los
Angeles people kind of assume that
there's like disconnect that there is a
superficiality that is rampant in Los
Angeles but those are really just people
that have only moved there to be in the
industry
thus meeting only people who are also
climbing ravenously to the top or trying
to otherwise um so yeah I think that we
get a bad rap for that but it um it's
right now it's like I lays I'm like I'm
very I'm extremely always extremely
eye-opening as somebody who grew up in
the vicinity of Calabasas do you find it
at all strange to see it like plastered
on Yeezys or like street wear as a
synonym for cool
oddly enough Calabasas high as where my
brother went to school and I always kind
of made fun of him a little bit because
it was like oh come on what you can't go
to Taft he like went to a really nice
school still public so to me look like
no nothing against Calabasas but if you
want to be cool you know like a little
less deep valley is to me cooler but I
don't know I feel like now I'm like
talking [ __ ] about Calabasas and I in no
way I'm just gonna Thomas this is sick
you know I just kind of had it like a
little bit of a like oh cool you're from
Calabasas Doh because you ready to move
on cruisin here
okay fork-and-knife I'm scared man all
right
I know that I have a ways to go before
it gets really scary but we're just
getting closer and closer now continuing
that climb yeah okay this one's so red
and I know that's the one that usually
gets people this made sure at least be
like scares me because she no she
wouldn't I mean it scares me just seemed
real yeah so once heard seth rogen say
something interesting about how the gaps
that you might fill in in a comedy to
let the audience laugh that it can
sometimes be a little bit awkward when
you're watching the movie at home
streaming on Netflix so in terms of
streaming yeah I think maybe things are
moving at a clip sometimes I like really
slow movies like certain things that I
find really interesting and cool
sometimes other people wouldn't and and
probably more and more do you fear the
day where everyone's just watching
movies on their phones like is something
lost in the experience of seeing a film
that way absolutely yeah but I also
think that people I think that there is
a commitment I think there's a film
culture that's not going anywhere at
least within my lifetime even if it
becomes sort of smaller that's fine with
me it doesn't need to be like insanely
expansive I think like this whole
industry of the Hollywood sort of like
Machine of it all if it came crashing
down I still think there'd be us weirdos
making weird little movies that we would
be showing each other and I would still
love it well-said are you ready to move
on no but you will yeah sure dude I'll
do anything there we go
[Music]
when I really dig something I'm eating I
always start dancing me too a little bit
we'll just start vibing over here yes so
what may it's not getting hotter per se
well enjoy that yeah okay enjoy them
yeah yeah yeah yeah totally
why is Tokyo must-visit destination for
you I know that you've done some press
runs there and then shot therefore
equals it's wild it's unpredictable I
really like the food did you visit that
a ski Gmarket that's like it must be
like the Promised Land for people who
love sushi oh yeah yeah yeah that was
really fun like the one they have to go
to really early in the morning right and
you see them like throwing large fish
around which actually now is kind of
deeply [ __ ] up but um yeah I went
there and I went with Nick Holt and I
didn't want to I we ate a bunch of sushi
and I didn't want to offend anyone and
they just kept giving me like all these
bites of kind of gnarly looking [ __ ] and
I kept going like just feeding the tank
he was like six o'clock in the morning I
don't think Nick Holt felt very well
after going there with me but I was like
dude you're eating this put it in your
mouth oh yeah it was fun
[Music]
this is when you get people to be like
I'm good at this game your skin you're
I'm scary double this one I'm scary I
can tell those eyes okay it's a crystal
we have our current segment on our show
called explain that Graham where we'll
have our guests explain some of the more
curious Instagram pictures but that's
impossible for you because you are off
the social media grid yeah so here
instead what we're gonna do is draw back
the mythology on some great Kristen
Stewart fit pics outfits mm-hmm
cuz GQ described your style as sick
freak casual a combination of luxe and
grunge putting vans old schools with a
ripped Beastie Boys t-shirt and a chanel
Grail I mean damn right do you know this
yellow lab or they just happened to
photobomb you the yellow lab photobombed
me and my friend show me that yesterday
and I was like I already like the outfit
but like I look really good with a dog
that's pride ously belong next to a dog
to a great fit pic is you gotta get a
lab to photobomb yeah let's not show Col
that hide up get make him jealous all
right next
this might that's a naked mole-rat
t-shirt from the Cheyenne Mountain Zoo
very rare find mmm I actually wore that
for my um that t-shirt for my closing
SNL whatever moment and I just thought
it was funny like somebody who wouldn't
normally want to like be super exposed I
felt like a naked mole rat on that show
I was like that's perfect I felt like my
teeth were sticking out like what's your
hack for finding the best vintage
t-shirt I keep my eyes open you know
also been like you know I've been in
I've been wearing t-shirts my whole day
on life I just know them everything but
you're put your $10,000 yeah all right
up next here you are doing a Finn selfie
what are the mechanics of that cuz you
know sometimes I find like when people
give you their phone maybe I'll get a
weird text maybe they'll get a phone
call no you have that thing but they
can't open the app and it's stuck and
they're like I sorta god this never
happens it's never how totally I just
take their phone from them and take the
picture take control of God
go yes yeah and then I know that some of
these picture is another taken by people
like maybe they're hanging out the
airport or hanging out outside of
restaurants do you have like a paparazzi
evasion like an experiment that you're
most proud of some ruse that you've
thrown them off the track over the years
move quickly watch them fall on their
asses which is like really annoying
direct them towards obstructions and
then divert and then they run into them
and they're like oh um what else yeah I
mean um you move quickly and keep your
head down basically don't give them
anything I guess I'll go back half onto
six here
[Music]
is this this one mm-hmm Pia Pia
this one's very red
[Music]
oh no it's legit though it's it's that
time I do like that feeling though when
you kind of feel like like that's why I
like spicy food so generating that kick
how does a love hot face not all spicy
things give that to you some things that
really burn your mouth don't make you
sweat this one's sweaty mm-hmm so when
we had Michael Cera on the show we got
really meta about the celebrity
interview and he had this really good
point about how sometimes he can look
like a jerk for no other reason than
he's just not matching the gigawatt
energy of whoever he's talking to sure a
similar vein I thought you had a great
quote that was really interesting where
you say people have to try to understand
that it's very weird for me to talk to
people I don't know about something I
care about so much you're like a really
well researched in like great interview
this is wild
so are you thanks so are you um you're
kind of expected to be like present and
candid and generous with people that are
the opposite of those things and when
you're around people that don't reflect
something true it's like what you think
it's my fault I seem like a weirdo it's
you so um basically yes indeed and yes I
want to be honest about the things I
care about and sometimes if I don't feel
like that's reciprocated I don't feel
like I owe it to that persist it along
to carry on trying desperately to sound
real when there's no environment in
which to do that and so then I seem like
the [ __ ] but I'm willing to do that
that's a hot one like that really is
legit I feel sweaty well
we have a few more to go here okay
having fun though it's cool you having a
good time
she's the anchor me so from bravado cool
I don't want to be a [ __ ] and take
small bites but this is scary
[Music]
so back in 2011 you declared your love
for food network and said that you're
obsessed with cooking
what's a loquat pie okay so in a way
there are these low quadtrees everywhere
and they're really hard to find you
don't find limit in like stores or
anything like that occasionally a
farmers market but it's like pretty
particular to the area and in a certain
time of the year it's like they really
go off so I do a little urban foraging
and I'm always scared I go at night
because I don't want anyone to come out
and be like get off my lawn but nobody
eats them and they're really really good
and when you put them in something with
a little sugar they caramelize really
nicely and become like candy and so my
specialty is a loquat crumble like any
other crumb will you out a little just a
tiny bit of sugar like whatever sort of
warmer spices you like and you know like
you could put like oats on top and like
butter if you eat that but there are you
know other versions of it that you can
make that are the begin and um the main
thing is just put the sugar on the
loquat and put it in the oven because
dope things happen to the skin it like
gets chewy I'm kind of you're doing
great it's this one no this is what made
Charlize like I thought you you're
screwed that's a I was like oh god but
now maybe it's me maybe one bite of that
I'm scared of Kristen Stewart and you
turn into the Hulk okay and flip this
table and take down the lights and it's
the last anyone's ever heard of me oh no
no we have to go there let's really go
there here we go you have to do this all
the time the [ __ ] is wrong with you
[Music]
sweet fine
everything is always not as bad as I
think you know this always happens to me
I'm always like I think it's good that I
always think everything's gonna [ __ ]
kill me and then when you're in the
moment I got it
do you have a favorite memory from that
Rolling Stones ride him on down music
video because you guys had a zebra was
you a 65 quite the treatment it is bad
yeah I had to dance a lot and I'm music
video and it was really embarrassing
I was in downtown El my god I was in
downtown LA I just saw someone on your
team do a double fisted yeah man I had
to like I don't like pole dance a
[ __ ] gas station thing that pumps gas
into cars
um I had my friends that what the
[ __ ] I had my friends there kind of
dancing like off-camera exciting feel
like I was dancing alone or like no one
is watching but [ __ ] you hard yeah hide
in the face yeah okay cool
it's a rough one yes what stands out
about playing Joan Jett in front of Joan
Jett like I always think that's an
interesting practice for an actor when
they're performing as someone who's
still alive it was scary
I thrive under pressure I think um I can
see it I can tell yeah I would have done
anything to do that woman justice and so
even if I had to you know theoretically
drop trou in front of her and really try
and pull it out
she made me all the better for it and
the thing that I played her in I loved
it and I would do it again alright Chris
are you ready to move on yeah I think
that we only it's actually better from
here I've seen the show I'm a huge fan I
think we're okay now I think the worst
is the worse it is
Yeah right
it's still we're still in it where's my
voice has never sounded like that also
it's the back of your mouth that sucks
ideas accumulation of all of these you
know stack and all these solutions
who's your favorite um well you can't
pick a favorite necessarily but like who
is really fun to do this with like were
you like whoa this person is wild well
there's certain episodes that if like I
would try to hook somebody on hot ones I
would say like uh
the Gordon Ramsay episode oh yeah I was
my Paul Rudd Shia LaBeouf
Charlize one of my favorites Scarlett
Johansson Kristen Stewart great that all
sounds really cool careful around your
eyes
no that's smart you did the I haven't
touched a thing was 30 go ahead oh I
just I'm curious to know how Shia was
cuz he's like a beast what he would do
is he'd pop the top on all of these and
he was just like oh my god let me get it
dude fuckin'-a you're like you're down
okay
was there any fallout from you screaming
the f-word on Saturday Night Live like
did you get a letter from like the FCC
or any sort of formal reprimand no it
went down I feel like people really
liked it I did Lauren came up to me
halfway well I guess right after that
before the next sketch and was like he
talked to me he was like looks like he
was talking to like a person who had
gone through like a serious trauma like
he was like it's okay don't worry we
still have a whole show to do I was like
I promise it's okay I won't do it again
and he was very nice and supportive
alright so I know that you grew up with
your parents in the film industry and
they decorate the house with like
various set pieces and props that they'd
pick up from the movies and as I
understand it and the Alice in
Wonderland themed wall was a quote from
the Queen of Hearts which reads no no
sentence first verdict afterwards do you
feel like that foreshadowed your
experience of living as a public figure
at all
yeah I mean I definitely didn't get in
it to be you know like like a famous
person or like stroke for whatever cool
things that you did and sort of
admonished forever forever for any bad
things that I did or whatever it can be
fun it can be weird it can be fake it
can be real I really just wanted to make
movies man and that that is that deaf I
think that was sort of embedded in me
and and it like a familial thing and I
don't I just sentences end and then more
hot wings happen more hot wings happen
but here on the last dab we have a very
special wing 10 we are excited to
welcome to the table a lemon sky yeah
and they only Scott skis boy together we
have the Charlie's Angels and we're here
because I'm the wing 10 it's tradition
to put a little extra on the last wing
great view by the way thanks for hanging
out thanks for hanging out and this is
the end of our day so we've done a bunch
of crap interviews so like that's great
it's a good thing this is the end of the
day can you imagine it really start I
don't tell me if it's worse doing the
last one yeah is it or is it better like
is it worse that we're going straight
into it or is it worse she's what cuz
she's obviously had more in her mouth
well as you can see I'm not sure you'd
trade places with Kristen right now no
but the downside is activated right now
yeah I'm exhilarated is that
you know it's such a steep ramp so
scruff well it's like saucy down here in
the dish a quick clogged up there
I don't really much it there's the thing
together we are stronger and hotter so I
feel like this gonna be better con touch
it I got it oh yeah that's enough great
you don't even love me no no no yeah but
she do we do we have to put someone yes
you don't have to if you don't well no
we caught it she's doing it so okay okay
here we go
I'm pretty scared yeah this is fantastic
you know you're just gonna I'm gonna do
a little zipper ooh on this guy smart so
I'm not gonna be a little [ __ ] of a
audience now oh great I'll go first
I was she yeah we need your fork hmm I
really got on the lips I think that's
gonna hurt your lips in it okay yeah I
also put the sassy end on the tongue
down we're just gonna jump in yeah you
know
oh my god you aren't really getting it
all right here we go you know what
here's get my I'm gonna send you home
this with this one and then you'll
really understand my pain
what do you think it's not good morning
it's not like we've been away the whole
day already I've now officially just
woken up
well closing it out it is the bucket of
BFF questions Oh
so hello you'll just reach in there
you'll pull out a question yeah and then
you'll ask it to the table I am Indian
that I say that's what I'm familiar I
had a lot of Mexico okay okay so much
worse when you exhale she's like sitting
I love seeing you like this hey my thing
is announcing ringing you're right yeah
got this okay have some almond milk
which of us is most like our character
in Charlie's Angels um okay so I think
that Ella is very much like yeah I can
show these angels she's pragmatic she's
she's a very perceptive very like
self-sufficient and she's an actual
ninja man like I don't want to like deal
all my stunts she wants to do that [ __ ]
if Charlie were to relay instruction to
us through the phone right now what
would he say jeez Trin and Barrett
[ __ ] you can do this by the way you
can do anything you put your mind to
well I am looking into three pairs of
inspirational eyes and look at you guys
coming in at the tail end bringing it
home and helping Kristen across the
finish line and now there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
you guys this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life oh um shit's hot
oh my god you're sweating I'm sweating
dude okay so I made these girls do this
with me because I don't want to do
anything alone and it's because we're
new movie called Charlie's Angels and
it's coming out soon and I really hope
everyone likes it because you know we
put everything we have into that show
[Music]
good job
well good job good job oh you can take
that with you I promise what the [ __ ]
what is up spice lards camera guy bill
here
I know we've retired the laptop this
season and you all miss me but I want
you to know that I'm still hard at work
behind the camera if you like today's
episode it would mean a lot to me and
the rest of the hot ones crew to give us
a little like or a little subscribe it
really mean a lot this camera guy bill
here saying it's good to be camera guy
bill
[Music]